this week on brian ross investigates
cult justice shocking videos from inside
a college cult
college students beaten
tortured
forced into sadistic sex acts
all coming out in court in the trial of
an alleged cult leader who targeted his
daughter's campus friends
using mind games to control them
did you in fact poison me yes absolutely
leading experts say college students is
at campuses across the country are being
targeted by cults we're joined by one of
the leading authorities on the subject
they believe that what they're doing
is for the greater good whatever that
might be
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz and rhonda we
begin tonight with cult justice the
chilling bizarre story that's been
unfolding in a federal courtroom here in
new york about what can only be
described as a sex cult on a college
campus run by the father of one of the
students larry ray a jury has now found
him guilty on all counts for what
prosecutors said was the use of his sway
over his daughter's friends and fellow
students at sarah lawrence college to
brainwash them brutalize them and turned
them into sex objects rhonda
that's right brian during the trial
jurors heard firsthand from the students
themselves and saw videos that show how
ray operated with threats and violence
and a warning to our viewers these
videos you're about to see are very
graphic
i need to go to the hospital
the graphic videos include ray
assaulting one of his cult members
felicia rosario
[Music]
you got to sit down on the floor
felicia
then the video shot by another cult
member shows the young woman sobbing in
rey's lap
[Music]
[Applause]
prosecutors say this student claudia
drury was forced into prostitution by
ray after he made this video to get her
to falsely confess she had tried to
poison him
did you in fact poison me yes absolutely
absolutely i did
okay
go ahead
i came up four
four times i think three times but every
time i've poisoned you
another video shows ray putting a pair
of pliers on the tongue of a student he
was unhappy with daniel levine do you
think i'm playing with you
you're wrong man i'm a wrong man
i don't like what you did
you hear me
now one more time and i want to put your
tongue in here you understand me
no
yeah yes
all very shocking we're joined now by
adam klausfeldt who is the manager
editor of law and crime.com and covered
this trial adam thank you so much for
being here tonight the jury was only out
for about five hours did that surprise
you
not at all brian this was a case that
produced overwhelming evidence and you
just saw the videos those videos show
the manipulation the brutalization of
these young sarah lawrence college
students and the jury got an earful and
eyeful of them prosecutors amassed
thousands of pieces of evidence and
painstakingly just laid it out there
over the course of nearly a month
together with powerful testimony it is
no surprise that it would take them only
five hours to reach an overwhelming
verdict of 15 counts of guilty and adam
this all began as larry ray moved into
his daughter's dormitory at sarah
lawrence college how does a parent move
into a dormitory and what happened once
he did
it is quite a surprising tale he
as you noted went into his daughter's
dormitory the dormitory's name is now
quite infamous sloanum woods nine
one of his victims wrote a book named
after that dorm he was invited there by
his daughter talia ray after a bitter
custody dispute with his former wife and
uh inserted himself into these kids
lives if there was evidence produced at
trial that the students had written to
administrators about larry's role in
their lives and i think a lot of people
are asking questions about the college
right now how this man
who a jury found guilty of these serious
serious charges was able to slip in
right into this college dormitory and do
this to these kids right adam a question
for you from rhonda schwartz rhonda
this has been described as the cult of
larry ray
how did he have such control over these
young people how did he sway them to his
will
well there was
expert testimony by a expert
psychologist for the government talking
about the grooming process and coercive
control
also what was introduced into evidence
was larry ray's reading material he was
keenly interested in subjects of mind
control into breaking the uh will of
these students and they amassed his
reading material they looked into what
he was uh what he was reading on the
internet and they
matched that and it was a pivot point
during the prosecution's summations
matching that with his actions and with
what the expert psychiatrist described
as grooming coercive control but the key
facet of larry ray and how he got that
done was by coercing confessions from
these students persuading them that they
were somehow poisoning him or colluding
with his enemies or trying to damage his
property and then trying to extract a
debt to that and he did that to the tune
of hundreds of thousands and in one case
millions of dollars from his victim
adam as in so many cases with coast as a
serious
component of sexual abuse and that was
true here
that was absolutely true here as a
matter of fact he was just convicted of
sex trafficking sex trafficking of one
of the victims claudia drury who gave
harrowing testimony for five days on the
witness stand talking about how
larry ray forced her into sex work where
she was working seven days a week on her
birthdays on holidays
in order to make money for larry ray she
testified she made 2.5 million dollars
sometimes to the tune of tens of
thousands of dollars a week and that
when she alerted a client that both she
and the client were being blackmailed
that he responded with what prosecutors
described as a long night of torture
seven to eight hours of it where it was
taped by his accused co-conspirator
isabella pollock and
it included things like near suffocation
with a plastic bag choking on a leash
and other depravities dousing her with
water next to an air conditioner is very
grisly testimony
and adam where does larry ray come from
what's known about his background
he has quite an interesting background
and one of the
mysteries of this case is trying to sort
out the fact from the fiction here's the
facts he was the
best man at the wedding of the former
new york city police commissioner bernie
carrick he also was prosecuted in a
federal securities fraud scheme in the
late 1990s it was actually came down
around 2000 the prosecution
in that case but he
was convicted and he served a sentence
of probation with that uh
before that time before that earlier
downfall he was mixing with uh pretty
powerful figures he was
seen with a russian president former
russian president
mikhail gorbachev he with uh new york
city mayor rudy giuliani there are
archival photos of that and it was so he
one of the ways that he exerted control
over these kids was to give them clues
as to his former life embellishing some
elements and
some elements actually checking out so
he
used his associations with the powerful
in order to persuade them that he was
connected to the worlds of military and
intelligence and also the underworld
he's set to be sentenced later this year
how much time does he face having been
found guilty on all these counts even on
one of the counts the maximum sentence
is life he has been found guilty of 15
counts and he's 62 years old he is
facing
a long time of imprisonment and quite
possibly life imprisonment all right
adam classville the managing editor of
law and crime.com thank you so much for
being with us here tonight and for your
excellent reporting throughout this case
very much ferdinand up next up next it
turns out college campuses have become a
big recruitment target for a number of
other cults across the country we'll
learn more from a leading authority
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
you